because it's being created within an
activity it can be terminated as simply
as rotating the phone into a different
orientation so should only ever be used
for tasks whose life cycle is tied to
the host activity and is expected to run
for only a second or two on mobile it's
unwise to assume that even the most
trivial Network access is going to
happen quickly so a better approach
would be to use a service an application
component without the UI that's less
likely to be interrupted possibly
scheduled using an inexact repeating
alarm even better Android has a
specialized solution known as a sync
adapter and it's designed especially to
schedule your background data syncs as
efficiently as possible better still
would be using Google Cloud messaging
this lets you notify your sync adapter
of changes on the server side so you're
only ever initiating Network requests
from your app when you know there's
something to be updated on the server
for now we're concentrating on making
our app work when it's in the foreground
full return to look at these approaches
to invisibly updating your app from the
background a little later and now keep
in mind that the refresh button and the
new threads solution is just a
placeholder while we hook up the rest of
the app